with the fourth and final season of the
good place fast approaching fans are
excited to see what happens to Jason
tejani
GT and Elinor as they attempt to get
into the real good place well here's
what we know about the upcoming season
so far
spoilers ahead the good place might seem
like a typical Network comedy but it
shirks convention and several important
ways for one thing all of its main
characters are dead except for a brief
time when they weren't forgive us for
stating the obvious
yeah basic thanks to its penchant for
philosophy complex plot points and
strong performances the series also
brings a distinct sense of prestige TV
to a network comedy well maybe not all
the time this please Chuy's also a
typical season of the good place runs
much shorter than your average TV show
there are fewer than 15 episodes per
season whereas most sitcoms feature 22
to 24 episodes per season here's some
good news for you the final season of
the good place will reportedly consist
of 14 episodes making it the longest
season in the show's history
what's more series creator Mike Schur
has announced that the finale will run
for a full hour
as great as that is it still signals the
end of a beloved show this sucks in June
2019 sure took to Twitter to announce
the show was ending writing at times
over the past few years we've been
tempted to go beyond four seasons but
mostly because making this show is a
rare creatively fulfilling joy that's
right the decision to end the show came
from the creative team rather than NBC
brass as sure tweeted given the ideas we
wanted to explore and the pace at which
we wanted to present those ideas I began
to feel like four seasons just over 50
episodes was the right lifespan not mad
just disappointed
on the upside at least the talented
folks behind the good place get to end a
show on their own terms if you need a
quick brush up seasons past you've come
to the right place the good place covers
a lot of ground from episode to episode
and it's a truly unpredictable show if
you don't believe us just look at all
these magical shrimp from the first
episode the show gets off to a running
start by introducing us to Eleanor
she'll strop portrayed by Kristen Bell
and
what a way to do it shortly after she
meets Michael played by Ted Danson she's
informed that she's full-on dead and has
been granted a spot in the good place
instead of the bad place cool cool I
have some questions don't you what
here's another twist the first of many
eleanor was a total dirtbag during her
time on earth and she doesn't actually
belong in the good place if you haven't
seen the show run away right now
because spoiler alert Eleanor isn't even
in the good place
[Music]
it's true at the end of the first season
Eleanor and her cohorts find out they're
actually in a bad place that was
specifically designed to torture them
eventually the humans team up with
Michael to work against the many demons
of the bad place upon discovering that
nobody has actually been admitted to the
good place in recent memory the game
decides to reboot their memories with
Michael's help that way they can work on
improving themselves in the afterlife
it's a last-ditch attempt to earn spots
in the real good place confused
get used to it you know what Michael
yeah basic Eleanor starts to suspect
she's been put in the good place by
mistake and subsequently embarks on a
mission to become a better person and
she's unluck because one of her
companions is Chiddy a professor of
ethics and moral philosophy once she
explains her dilemma he reluctantly
agrees to teach her how to become a
better person getting a stomachache I'm
in a perfect utopia and I have a
stomachache there is a whole lot of
philosophy in the good place a show that
references everyone from cons to
Kierkegaard yet it somehow remains
utterly hilarious while doing so as the
New York Times notes the most refreshing
thing about the good place in an era of
artistic bleakness is it optimism about
human nature it's made humane and
side-splitting way entertaining
television out of the notion that people
and even the occasional immortal demon
are redeemable thanks to its endlessly
inventive and hilarious premise the good
place earned excellent reviews right out
of the gate and that sinister yet silly
twist at the end of the first season
really made people pay attention
Pulitzer Prize winning critic Emily
Nussbaum wrote what we got was the rare
season finale that could legitimately be
described as a game changer vaulting the
show from a Daffy screwball comedy to
something darker much stranger and
uncomfortably appropriate for our
apocalyptic era speaking of high praise
in 2019 Kristen Bell was nominated for a
Golden Globe for Best Performance by an
actress and a television series Musical
or Comedy
put alas she ultimately lost to Rachel
Brosnahan the star of the marvelous mrs.
Mazal
you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me
nevertheless the good place won a
prestigious Peabody Award in April 2019
and it secured its first ever nomination
for Outstanding Comedy Series at the
2019 Emmys on the whole that's none too
shabby after Mike Schur success with the
office and Parks and Recreation it's not
surprising that NBC wanted to work with
him again when he pitched the show that
eventually became the good place the
network was instantly sold on the idea
in fact NBC execs committed to a
13-episode season before a single
episode had been produced prior to its
premiere in 2016 the show was shrouded
in secrecy but sure did make it known
that he loosely modeled the show on
ABC's massive hit lost in fact Damon
Lindelof the executive producer of lost
and the leftovers worked with sure to
come up with a good place of central
concept sure wanted to create a show
that tied together philosophy religion
comedy and the afterlife it's a lot to
wrap one's head around isn't it I'm
sorry I'm trying to process a tremendous
amount of insane information
nevertheless sure succeeded in creating
one of the most unique shows to ever air
on network TV so at the end of season
one we learned that the good place is an
experiment created by Michael to torment
the poor souls who wound up there you
thought we would torture each other and
we did for a little but we also took
care of each other it sounds like the
final season we'll continue to explore
this conceit with some fresh faces
thrown into the mix make sure told The
Hollywood Reporter they're going to
repeat this grand experiment and see
what happens when it's new people their
rager is that any group of people if
given a certain amount of love support
empathy and help can become better that
essentially no one is beyond
rehabilitation meanwhile William Jackson
Harper the actor who plays Qi D told TV
insider we're starting in a very
different place where the six of us are
not all on the same page at all so it
leads to some really interesting
dynamics and I think it'll be a really
interesting watch but that's about all I
can say the good place doesn't have a
huge cast but two notable names have
been attached to the show from the
beginning Kristen Bell and Ted Danson
Danson of course is a comedy legend best
known for his work as Sam Malone on
Cheers
sitcom heyday he's appeared in shows
like bored to death CSI and Curb Your
Enthusiasm asked for bail she played the
titular teenage detective on Veronica
Mars and then went on to appear in films
including forgetting sarah marshall the
boss and couples retreats to name just a
few
of course Belle has since reprised her
role as Veronica Mars in both a feature
film and a Kulu revival of the series
it's not a stretch to say that the good
police boasts one of the most talented
casts on network television and several
of them were relatively unknown swen the
series began William Jackson Harper was
cast early on
followed by British television presenter
Jameela Jamil in her first acting role
then there's Manny Jacinto another
newcomer the final piece of the puzzle
is Darcy Cardin the brilliant comedic
actress who plays the role of Janet
she's sort of like the afterlife's
answered a Siri I mean it does matter if
I know things because I'm an
informational delivery system and I
don't have a heart
but thanks over the course of three
seasons the good place has continued to
expand its supporting cast notable
additions include more Kevin Jackson who
plays a bad police bureaucrat named Sean
then their Saturday Night Live standout
Maya Rudolph who plays an all-powerful
and exceptionally baddie judge that's to
say nothing of Kirby how will Baptiste
the British actress who plays Simone
she's a neuroscientist who strikes up a
relationship with Chiti when the group
finds themselves back on earth well what
we do is we make a lengthy incision from
your eyebrows to the knife of your neck
and we peel your face back right then
slice your skull open
according to sure there will be some
exciting new additions to the cast in
season four in an interview with TV Line
he said that the final season will focus
on a full reboot of the main gangs
memories in the afterlife each of them
will be confronted by someone who is
specifically engineered to torture them
to honey and she Dee's torturers were
revealed in the third season but Eleanor
and Jason's worst nightmares are still
unknown to us and them as sure puts it
the idea was that the bad place chose
the people they chose to specifically
kind of smart-bomb our original crew
they're just people whose personalities
are specifically designed to ruin the
lives of one individual so we really
spent a lot of time trying to figure out
what that would mean for the final two
residents
didn't reveal any specifics beyond that
but bringing these tormentors to life
will almost certainly add some memorable
players to an already excellent cast
clearly the good place has made a name
for itself as one of the most
life-affirming shows on television no
small feat for a show about a bunch of
dead people well it sounds like the
final season is going to pack an
emotional punch the creative team is
keeping major plot details under wraps
but after Manny Jacinto did hint at a
touching final season telling E online I
think it'll really hit the heartstrings
I mean last season's finale was
definitely kind of hitting people in the
fields but I think this season we've
kind of headed in that kind of sort of
direction meanwhile Mike sure has
promised not to end the final season on
a cliffhanger we bet that he's cooked up
a solid and satisfying ending to this
unusually complex show the mystery of
Michael the character is played to
perfection by Ted Danson who manages to
always be incredibly charming and
charismatic even when he's indulging his
most diabolical impulses they're at each
other's throats already this should put
them over the top and you play Bart a
former private eye even though Michael
is a demon with access to all the
knowledge in the universe audiences
still don't know a whole lot about him
he's made several references to his
advanced age and the fact that he's
merely inhabiting a human body but how
does that work exactly
Mike sure has all but confirmed that
audiences will soon find out
telling Rolling Stone you will learn a
lot more about Michael's corporeal form
in the fourth episode of this season and
that's not the only revelation they have
in store for us as you've no doubt
noticed the concept of soulmates runs
through the entire show
notice our beautiful tonight
regular-sized pockets I get Asajj
soulmates well you can reportedly expect
the idea of soulmates to be further
explored and developed in the final
season in season two fans only saw brief
flashes of the reboots Michael
orchestrated in order to trick Eleanor
gd2 honey and Jason according to Mike
sure some of these reboots will be
explored further in the final season
speaking to Vanity Fair
he said there's a lot of stuff that
happens this year where we sort of
revisit the different versions of
Michael that have existed over the time
of the show
starting with the demon version and
going through the middle versions and
going through the inversions and that
brings us to the biggest question how
will the good police ultimately conclude
Kristen Bell seems to know something but
she's keeping her cards close to her
chest Conan O'Brien asked whether she
knows how the show ends and she
responded I forgot I'm legit forgot did
you really yeah so he told you where
it's going and you forgot
well we'll be getting some answers soon
enough season four of the good place
premieres on Thursday September 26th at
9 p.m. Eastern Time check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite films
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]